let's uh
try to at this moment steal man
the argument for the natural origin of
the virus so just uh to clarify
so wuhan is actually despite what it
might sound like to people is a pretty
big city there's a lot of people that
live in it 11 million so not only is
there the wuhan institute of virology
there's other centers that do
work on viruses yes
but there's also a giant number of
markets and everything we're talking
about here is pretty close together so
when i kind of look at the geography of
this
i think when you zoom out it's all wuhan
but when you zoom in there's just a lot
of interesting dynamics that could be
happening and what the cases are popping
up and what's being reported all that
kind of stuff
so i think the people that
argue for the
natural origin and there's a few recent
papers that come out arguing this
it's kind of fascinating to watch this
whole thing but i think what they're
arguing is that there's this hunan
market that's one of the major markets
uh the wet markets in uh wuhan
that uh there's a bunch of cases
that were reported from there
so if i look at for example the michael
warby
perspective that he wrote in science he
argues he wrote this a few days ago
the the predominance of early covet
cases linked to hunan market and this
can't be dismissed as ascertainment bias
which i think is what people argue that
you're just kind of focusing on this
region because a lot of cases came but
there could be a huge number of other
cases
so people who argue against this say
that this is a later stage already right
um
so he says no he says this is this is
the epicenter
and uh this is a clear
evidence that uh circumstantial evidence
but evidence nevertheless that
this is where the jump happened
to humans the big explosion maybe not
case zero i don't know if he argues that
but with the early cases so what do you
make of this whole idea can you steal
man it yeah before yeah so
and my
goal here isn't to attack people on on
the other side and and if my feeling is
if there is evidence that's presented um
that that should change my view i i hope
that i'll be open-minded enough to
change my view and certainly michael
warby is a thoughtful person a
respectful a respected scientist and and
i think this work is is contributive
work but i just don't think um that it
it
that it's as significant as has been
reported in in in the press and so what
his argument is um is that there is an
early
cluster in december of 2019 around the
the juan on seafood market and even
though he himself
argues that the original
breakthrough case the original case the
index case where the first person
infected
happened earlier happened in october or
november so not in december his argument
is well what are the odds that you would
have this number this cluster of cases
in the juan seafood market and if the
origin happened someplace else wouldn't
you expect other
other clusters and it's not an entirely
implausible argument but there are
reasons why i think it's uh that it's
this is not nearly as determinative as
has been reported and i certainly had a
lot of
others had tweeted a lot about this
and that is first uh the the people who
were infected in this cluster it's not
the earliest known uh virus of the
sarsko v2 it began mutating so this is
it's not the original sarsko v2 there so
you it had to have happened someplace
else too the people who were infected in
the market
weren't infected in the part of the
market where they had these kinds of
animals that are considered to be
candidates
for as in intramural intermediary
species and third there was a bias
actually i'll have four things uh third
there was a bias in the early
assessment in china of what they were
looking for they were asked did you have
exposure to the market because i think
in the early days when people were
figuring things out that was one of the
questions that uh that was asked and
fourth and probably most significantly
we have so little information
about those early cases in china and
that's really unfortunate i know we'll
talk about this later because the
chinese government is preventing access
to all of that information which they
have which could easily help us get to
the bottom at least know a ton more
about how this pandemic started and so
this is it it's like grasping at straws
in the dark with gloves on that's right
but the steel man the argument we have
this evidence from this market
and yes the chinese government has
turned off the lights essentially so we
have very little data to work with but
this is the data we have
so who's to say that this data doesn't
represent a much bigger
data set that a lot of people got
infected at this market where it even at
the parts or especially at the parts
with the the meat
the infected meat was being sold so that
could be true and it probably is true
the question is
is this the source is this the place
where this began or was did this just a
place where it was amplified and i
certainly think that it's
it's extremely likely that the juan
seafood market was a point of
amplification and it's just answering a
different question basically what you're
saying is it's very difficult to use the
market as evidence for anything
because
it's probably not even the starting
point so it's just a good place for it
to continue spreading that's certainly
my view what michael warabi's argument
is um
is that well what are the odds of that
that we're seeing this amplification at
this particular in the market and
if we if let me put this way if we had
all of the information if if the chinese
government hadn't blocked access to all
of this because there's blood bank
information there's all sorts of
information
and
based on a full and complete
understanding
we came to believe that all of the early
cases
were at this market i think that would
be
a stronger argument than uh what this is
so far but everything leads to the fact
that why is it that the chinese
government
which was
frankly after a slow start the gold
standard of doing viral tracking for
sars one
why have they apparently done so little
and shared so little i think it it asks
it it begs a lot of questions
you